[Musica]
la macchina era molto credo che ci
troviamo il soca tanto di bandiere ne
restano i periti per venir evacuati
devono fare
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo a bordo della nave da guerra russa
ammira yokoo le coop in missione nel
mediterraneo di fronte le coste siriane
un attentatore suicida si sta
avvicinando alla prima linea nel centro
di colpirlo per farle esplodere
si fa saltare loro barca è appena
arrivato una razza razza e di un bar
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo è il mio biglietto da visita da
35 anni so fare solo questo è il
giornalista di guerra senza se e senza
ma e scatto immagini come queste che mi
stanno particolarmente a cuore perché
quelle orbite rossastre di questo
bambino soldato ugandese è quello
sguardo triste sono i veri occhi della
guerra ma gli occhi della guerra sono
anche l'ultimo rigagnolo lampo di vita
nello sguardo di un ferito morente gli
occhi della guerra sono quelli che
abbiamo incrociato dei prigionieri
terrorizzati perché catturati sul campo
di battaglia e che temono di venire
passati per le armi gli occhi della
guerra sono gli occhi dei civili lo
sguardo sconfitto senza speranza di chi
scappa dal conflitto
e non dimentichiamo che la maggioranza
delle vittime di ogni guerra è composta
da civili non da soldati ma gli occhi
della guerra siamo anche noi giornalisti
che attratti fatalmente da questi
conflitti esotici dimenticati o talvolta
addirittura alle porte di casa
noi che raccontiamo reportage guerre
conflitti che non sono più un mestiere
ma sono la mia vita
anzi la mia d'annata e maledetta
passione
mia moglie dice sempre che l'afghanistan
è la mia seconda patria
ci sono stato la prima volta quando
portava i calzoni corti nel 1983 durante
l'invasione
sovietica e poi ci sono sempre tornato
per raccontare i drammatici momenti di
questo tunnel lungo 40 anni di conflitto
e di guerra che non è ancora ancora
finito e l'undici settembre subito dopo
l'attacco alle torri gemelle sono corso
in afghanistan e dopo due mesi con i
bombardamenti dei b52 americani sulle
postazioni talebane con i colleghi
inglesi dei giornalisti inglesi abbiamo
fatto una scommessa quando entreremo a
kabul
liberata dai talebani e io ho puntato
subito su 13 novembre 2001 beh musei
dean mi hanno fatto un grande regalo
perché quel giorno era il mio
quarantesimo compleanno e con loro sono
entrato a kabul
e questo è il racconto in diretta per
radio di quelle ore incredibile e
indimenticabili al fronte delle
operazioni militari cioè per noi fausto
biloslavo immune vista lo sparando con
la terra come potete sentire
per il carnevale da questa mattina la
voce è stato asfaltato verso kabul si è
riempita di musei di rincari armati
blindati diretto ad essere prive di
allevare i soldati hanno addirittura
sequestrato i variopinti forma civili
per raggiungere il fronte
ora ci troviamo dietro alcuni container
sono un paio di chilometri della prima
linea dove esistono lanciando una serie
di razzi terra terra verso le postazioni
talebane
abbiamo sentito dal compagno di
cannonate sembra proprio che stia
iniziando il conto alla rovescia per
l'avanzata verso kabul fausto biloslavo
dal fronte a nord della capitale afghana
radio24 il sole24ore la passione per
questo mestiere cozza talvolta con la
realtà
questa è una delle poche foto poche
storie che mi sono state censurate l'ho
scartata nel 2004 in afghanistan sotto
quel telo mimetico c'è uno dei nostri
caduti tra l'altro un ragazzo un giovane
alpino proprio di queste terre del terra
dell'italia del sud
ho mandato l'articolo in redazione ho
mandato anche la foto il pezzo
l'articolo è uscito la foto no è
intervenuto direttamente il ministro
della difesa sul direttore del giornale
per non far pubblicare questa foto
perché una foto stile vieta nella foto
drammatica che racconta un'altra storia
rispetto al leit motiv governativo che
era quello delle missioni di pace che
era quello che portiamo le caramelle ai
bambini sapevamo portale molto bene le
caramelle bellini però anche
combattevamo facevamo la guerra subivamo
delle perdite e come in ogni guerra ma
mi sta più a cuore questa foto che non è
stata censurata perché dietro questo
ragazzino afghano che ha perso tutte e
due le gambe in un campo minato
c'è un amico
che si chiama alberto cairo e che ha una
passione più grande e più importante
della della mia lavora con la croce
rossa internazionale new york times l'ha
definito l'angelo di kabul
perché torna a far camminare i bambini
come questi ogni anno cairo con la croce
rossa internazionale realizza 20.000
protesi che significa gambe e braccia
artificiale per chi ha perso gli arti
in questo terribile conflitto ma
guardate i particolari
questo bambino tornerà a camminare
tornerà anche ad andare in bicicletta e
darà anche qualche calcio al pallone
grazie a quello che alberto si è
inventato ovviamente non sarebbe
possibile con una gamba di legno ma con
questi arti artificiali alberto via ha
realizzato anche le ginocchia
artificiali le caviglie alti ufficiali
ovviamente devono essere un attimo
snodabili per poter camminare e ha
scoperto che recuperando i pneumatici di
gomma dura piena senza camera d'aria di
tutti i blindati tutte le carcasse dei
blindati in cui è disseminato
l'afghanistan
fondendo questa gomma dura e piena crea
la perfetta articolazione artificiale e
per queste protesi il messaggio quale
che da uno strumento di guerra che è
single nato l'afghanistan si può trovare
una speranza per far tornare a camminare
i bambini che sono saltati sulle mine io
ho voluto una vita pericolosa e e l'ho
trovata
sono stato scarcerato incarcera ha
catturato dai sovietici in afghanistan
negli anni 80 durante la portasse con i
giardini o fatto sette mesi di galera
kabul sono tornato a kabul hanno cercato
di farmi fuori
sono stato per sei mesi in sedia a
rotelle ma poi sono tornato a
imbracciare la mia
la passione in libano mi hanno sbattuto
contro un muro per fucilarmi in kosovo
sono finito in un'imboscata e scappando
via correndo vedevo davanti ai miei
piedi traccianti delle raffiche che si
infilavano nel terreno e in afghanistan
la mia seconda patria sono saltate in
aria con gli italiani su una trappola
esplosiva dei talebani i famigerati
ordigni improvvisati chiamati in gergo
jedi sono l'arma più temibile dei
talebani che dissotterrano le piste
questo è il filmato ripreso da un
velivolo senza pilota di un blindato
italiano che salta in aria a bordo del
mezzo con quattro alpini del 32esimo
genio guastatori di torino
c'ero anch'io a filmare i drammatici
momenti subito dopo l'esplosione
grazie a 14 tonnellate di corazza siamo
rimasti tutti illesi
[Musica]
porto il demonio allora il mezzo riesce
a far land avanti in mezzo
il meteo è saltato la parte davanti
aspetta aspetta fermi in mezzo non lo
muovo che controlliamo se c'è qualcosa
intorno fermi non scendete sì lo so
questa questo è un pugno nello stomaco
ma nella vita di ogni giornalista di
guerra dei miei questo nome a un certo
punto la passione cozza con l'orrore io
la chiamo la sottile linea rossa perché
di fronte a questo orrore nella savana
africana questi mucchi di cadaveri
comprese donne e bambini
mi sono chiesto ma che ci faccio qui non
aveva forse ragione mia madre a dirmi ma
trovati un posto tranquillo in banca in
posta e invece io dovevo essere essere
la perché questa è una storia drammatica
e incredibile questi pazzi facevano
parte di lord del lord's resistance army
un gruppo armato guerriero ugandese che
era guidato da una sacerdotessa passa
come loro che si chiamava lice la pena
una cristiana nei mista che la notte
prima nella boscaglia nella foresta
fatto un rito voodoo e li ha convinti
che con olio magico ricavato da alcune
bacche se se lo spalmavano sul corpo
sarebbero stati immortali io ho portato
a casa una di quelle banche uno dei
proiettili di kalashnikov intrisi di
sangue che ammazzato
uno di questi per non dimenticare la
follia della guerra e all'alba tragica
della savana tutti questi pazzi in un
unica
linea sono avanzati cantando marciando e
appunto cantando siamo immortali sono
stati tutti falciati e allora ho capito
che di fronte a questa linea rossa
dovevo accendermi un cigarillos perché
il lesso della morte soprattutto
soprattutto all'equatore terribile
comincerà a prendere appunti sul block
notes scattare foto filmare e raccontare
questa drammatica storia ma uno si può
chiedere ma cosa ci trovino nella nella
guerra cos'è sta la passione in realtà
della guerra la guerra in qualche
maniera ti attrae perché nella guerra
c'è l'estremo del male ma anche del bene
in questo caso cioè trovi i padri di
famiglia alle madri che difendono quel
loro corpo come scudi umani i loro figli
e muoiono per questo e trovi i bonus i
boia di guerra come questo signore che
sentirete parole chiave italiano perché
le aveva imparato a san vittore in una
guerra alle porte di casa l'ho
incontrato a vukovar in croazia la
stalingrado croata era zeliko ragionato
vice detto arcane l'intoccabile
comandante delle tigri serbe ascoltate
cosa mi dice vanno presi due dei miei
soldati e hanno torturati allo tagliati
in mano uno hanno cosi terribile agli
organi genitali sono tutti bruciati con
la sigaretta mi è armata non prende mai
il prigionieri più ma non noi non
torturiamo prigionieri soldati di questa
se noi ma siamo loro a colpo subito ma
siamo loro a colpo subito
per me gli eroi sono questo ragazzino
akhmed che ha avuto metà braccio
tagliato via da una granata in una
cannonata inglese e soprattutto la sua
famiglia che però mi ha raccontato tutta
la storia non solo una parte sarebbe
stato troppo facile durante l'invasione
è alleata dell'iraq era seguito delle
truppe americane inglese appunto
raccontare appunto dei cattivi inglesi
che sparano sui ragazzini ma la verità è
che questa famiglia stava all'ultimo
piano di un palazzo che dominava un'area
residenziale dove si piazzarono dei
fedayn saddam
i fedelissimi di saddam hussein e il
padre andrò a parlamentare con loro se
avete d'armi sud e solette cosa volete
fare contro una colonna di trenta
carrarmati che sta arrivando moriremo
tutti loro risposero se volontari alla
per saddam possiamo proprio morire tutti
e di fatti arrivare la colonna inglese
il primo carro venne colpito da questi
da questi pazzi ma ovviamente non
riusciva neanche a scalfirlo alzò il
cannone tira una cannonata polverizzò la
postazione irachena ma una scheggia
entrò anche nell appartamento all'ultimo
piano il pensiero nascosto sotto il
letto sfondo eletto e l'italia di secco
in maniera secca metà braccio ma questa
è tutta la storia forse una piccola
tragica storia di quella guerra che
forse però riflette appunto la grande
storia di quel conflitto mai avrei
pensato di incontrare il colonnello
gheddafi
e se all'ultimo giornalista
intervistarlo prima della sua morte mai
avrei pensato che lui aveva previsto
tutto
gheddafi sarà un personaggio particolare
quando gli chiesi
eravamo in mezzo alla rivolta già due
mesi di rivolta armata si sparava a
tripoli attorno alla sua roccaforte
ed eravamo alla vigilia dei
bombardamenti della nato che abbatterono
il regime quasi a quando gli chiesi il
suo amico berlusconi mi disse e mi ha
tradito nome lo sentiva che non era così
critico insomma erano ancora amici
quando gli chiesi degli inglesi fu più
duro ma quando gli chiese il presidente
francese sarkozy
eh si proprio si avvicinò mi guardo
negli occhi e fece questo segno così del
picchiate del picchiatello ma
soprattutto soprattutto lasciare
l'ultima domanda più delicata alla fine
e gli chiesi colonnello ma lei non teme
di fare la fine di saddam hussein
impiccato nel suo popolo dal suo popolo
e interpreta sbiancò cioè un lenzuolo e
tentennando balbettando mi disse io non
posso tradurre questa domanda non prova
in inglese e in arabo eccetera solo che
gheddafi si mise a ridere perché aveva
fatto l'accademia militare in
inghilterra quindi capiva benissimo cosa
li stavo lì stavo chiedendo e anche
questo caso ha previsto la sua morte non
andrò mai via da questo paese si allarmò
proporrà morirò fra le dune del mio del
mio deserto ma soprattutto aveva
previsto quello che la libia sarebbe
diventata dopo i terroristi
mi disse arriveranno alle coste della
libia alle coste sulle sponde del
mediterraneo di fronte a voi così è
stato perderete tutte le nostre risorse
energetiche il gas il petrolio che che
e stata esportando così è stato e un
milione di africani arriveranno a casa
vostra
e così sta sta accadendo e allora la mia
domanda è ma forse si stava meglio
quando si stava peggio con gheddafi
io qualche maniera per 6 sì soprattutto
a vedere queste immagini che ho scattato
pochi mesi fa nel 2017 nei centri di
detenzione in libia dove i migranti
vengono tenuti chiusi dietro le sbarre
come schiavi io non sono un buonista e
quelli che dicono
apriamo le porte a tutti o cose di
questo genere però mi chiedo dov'era
loro dovesse dov'erano ng quando questi
nigeriani non aspettavano altro che di
essere rimpatriati perché in libia un
reato l'immigrazione e quindi devono
presidi tg1 la da otto mesi e qualcuno
da un anno dove era quelli che li
dovevano rimpatriare riportarli a casa
per chiudere questo girone girone
dantesco
sto andando oltre l'ultimo anno l'ho
vissuto ancora più pericolo per
pericolosamente ho voluto raccontare il
crollo del califfato la sconfitta delle
sue capitali la liberazione sue capitali
a sirte in libia a raqqa in siria e a
mossul in iraq forse la battaglia più
dura
vi faccio vedere solo uno spezzone
perché sono sono sono fuori fuori tempo
la battaglia più dura e uno giustamente
mi potrebbe chiedere ma chi te lo fa
fare
no a infilarti in quell'inferno beh
sicuramente non certo i soldi non certo
la fama di nuovo la passione i pezzi di
mino slavo
guardatelo con attenzione
[Applauso]
ma buoni
la battaglia per conquistare la capitale
dello stato islamico in iraq continua
più aspra che mai della battaglia
poi è stato proclamato e kalifa nella
città vecchia attorno al minareto perde
per le mosche alboury si sta combattendo
lo scontro finale con gli elicotteri che
martellano dal cielo
o sull'ovest era stato in grado delle
bandiere nere ridotta ad un cumulo di
macerie
i giornalisti vengono protetti dai
blindati per raggiungere la chiesa di
santa maria del perpetuo soccorso da
poco liberato un luogo di culto
cristiano è stato prima raziano e poi
devastato dai combattimenti
lo stato islamico aveva trasformato la
chiesa in una base jihadismo la
battaglia ma in ogni guerra c'è sempre
un piccolo barlume di speranza questo è
un padre che ha salvato suo figlio
neonato nato sotto le bombe proprio
nella battaglia di mossul
ho scattato questa foto quando è uscito
dall'inferno
ma vorrei concludere ringraziarvi per
l'attenzione soprattutto in questa
bellissima cappella della reggia di
caserta
le cui colonne portano ancora i segni di
una guerra lontana delle bombe della
seconda guerra mondiale raccontandovi
cosa faccio
quando torno a casa dai reportage
io sono nato a trieste vivo a trieste e
voglio sempre prendere il treno perchè
il treno costeggia passano lungo la
costiera e vedo il golfo di trieste che
non sarà bello come quello di napoli ma
per me è tutto vedo le luci della mia
città e mi torna alla mente come un film
gli orrori della guerra che ho appena
lasciato alle spalle e mi rendo ogni
volta conto di quanto siamo dannatamente
fortunati a vivere da 70 anni in pace
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]